good morning John it's Wednesday
February 18th and I wanted to
reintroduce you to my friend Hank sock
because he can do something that you
didn't think that he could do
I can talk that's right we're going on
the road me and Hank sock ventriloquist
act extraordinaire Hank sock and I were
thinking about going to see a movie but
then we realized movies is you really
think that's true for the most part for
the most part those with two exceptions
yeah I guess what are your exceptions
well uh Coraline and uh Slumdog
Millionaire yeah yes doesn't mind too
interesting Coraline was absolutely
beautiful
oh just like the prettiest movie I've
ever seen in my life and we love Neil
Gaiman yeah and they might be giants so
go see Coraline for sure they're not
paying me to say this
haengsuk and i actually decided that
there were a lot of movies that could
have been way better if they had only
had one word in their title changed like
wouldn't it be amazing if Bride Wars
instead of being Bride Wars was
guerrilla wars and you have underworld
the rise of the Lycans which would be
way better if it were underworld the
rise of the liger
speaking of which Hotel for Dogs should
probably be hotel for ligers and then we
have paul blart mall cop which would
definitely be better if it were Paul
Bart's mall cop and he was a diminutive
detective and he solves crime and keep
people's asked to spite the fact he was
four feet tall and finally confessions
of a shopaholic would probably be better
if it were confessions of an anything
else a holic and while we're at it it
might as well start David Duchovny
thanks uh can I also want to tell you a
little bit of a story about the guy who
proposed to his girlfriend via me on
brotherhood 2.0 point 0.9 the other day
ah congratulations in order
indeed pink sock they are so I gotta
tell us about it well I'm about to that
that resourceful nerdfighter snuck into
his girlfriend now fiancees house that
day hid in her attic and waited for her
to check vlogbrothers as well as cute
with Chris and stuff on my cat I
certainly got a lot of people involved I
know seriously I wish I thought of this
stuff and then can you guess now and
then right as she was coming home
instead of checking vlogbrothers and
stuff on my cat and key with Chris she
decided that she would put away her
Christmas tree stand which she had
outside
and of course the Christmas tree stand
goes we're in the Attic that's right so
she was like Harrison what are you doing
in the Attic haha
and he was like ah how about you come
over and I'll show you something and she
said yes
yay congratulate you pink sock is there
anything else that we wanted to talk
about today well maybe that your brand
new album is finally out on iTunes
well you can buy it today thanks I don't
like to be too overtly commercial on
these things but well it's a really good
album
thank you but yes it's available on
iTunes now of the link is in the sidebar
what we're where's a sidebar
where's like I'm never actually sure
what such a sidebars on but where is it
I'm sure you kind of I do if you look
hard enough hmm
anyway John I'll see you soon all right
okay talk you are kinda